Hello, my name is Zisl Slepovitch
and I'm musician in residence at Yale
University's Fortunoff Video Archive
for Holocaust Testimonies.
This video series is designed as a
companion to our album, Where
Is Our Homeland, which is the first
volume in the archives' ongoing effort
to present songs and poems
performed by survivors in testimonies
given to the Fortunoff Archive
over the last 40 years.
You can learn more about the project
on the Archive's website
songsfromtestimonies.org.
Where Is Our Homeland?
Songs from Testimonies.
Volume One was recorded in 2019
by the Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble,
featuring renowned singer Sasha
Lurje, Craig Judelman on
the violin, Joshua Camp on the
accordion, keyboards and guitar,
Dmitry Ishenko on the bass,
and myself on woodwinds.
The songs in this collection differ
vastly in terms of style, social
and historical background, language
and many other aspects.
But collectively they create
a multidimensional picture of
Jewish life before and during
World War II.
In this episode, we're going to talk
about and listen to another
song from Liubov' K.'s
testimony "Tuchi nad
Budishchem Vstali," "The
Clouds Gather Over Budishchem."
It is noteworthy that the entire
Fortunoff Video Archive music
project started in 2018
with Liubov's testimony.
With the Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble,
featuring the wonderful and
world-renowned singer Sasha Lurje,
we have recorded two albums,
26 songs in total,
and I'm preparing two other volumes
to be recorded
with really fascinating
and unique repertoire.
"Tuchi nad Budishchem Vstali"
is a retexting
and melodic adaptation
of Pavel Armand's music
and lyrics for the song "Tuchi
nad gorodom Vstali,"
"The Clouds Gathered Over the City,"
performed by the popular Soviet
actor and singer Mark
Bernes in the Sergei
Yutkevich's 1938
film Chelovek s Ruzhyom,
The Man With a Gun.
The song quickly gained popularity.
Arman's text conveys the heartbreak
of a young man who's going to the
war and is bidding farewell
to the young woman he loves.
The labor camp version, shared by
Liubov', depicts the horrific
realities of slave labor,
hunger, cold, lack
of basic living facilities,
and the cruelty of the Ukrainian
guard, Stepan.
The song has the time and feel of
a waltz, one of the most popular
genres in the 1930s
Soviet urban culture.
The clouds over Budyshche turn to steel.
In the camp it stinks of weak broth.
People fight over bones.
Chaika is running
around with a fire poker--
That was one mean cook there.
Stop all the noise people!
Go stand in line for the soup.
And then go get some rest
On the hay in the unheated club house.
The slop here isn’t so bad —
This thin broth of millet and water.
It could take you an hour
To find one pellet of millet in there
But friends, don’t despair,
They’ll bring in a blind nag,
And you can forget about any bread.
They’ll feed us a crumb once a week.
The nights fly by so quickly.
It’s morning and time for work.
All day long we waste away,
Freezing in the bitter frost.
It’s hard to go to work—
The German comes out to meet us.
He gives us our tasks — better be strong —
He’ll see to its completion.
Like an arrow we fly home,
One thought on everyone’s mind:
To reach camp, toss the shovels
And quickly run off to the village.
It’s hard to run to the
village, but returning is harder.
God forbid Stepan should
catch you at the door,
And give you red stripes.
God forbid Stepan should
catch you at the door,
And give you red stripes.
But we aren’t afraid of the lashing,
And the ramrod doesn’t hurt at all.
We’re ready to endure it all,
Only to make it to another day.
It’s hard to make it to another day,
Unheard-of torments to endure.
But in such damp dirt
Young girls would rather not lay.
But hope is what ever sustains us,
Hope keeps us ever alive.
They are slashing the wings of the eagle —
Then we will ascend the path of joy.
The clouds over Budyshche turn to steel
In the camp it stinks of weak broth.
People fight over bones.
Chaika is running around with a fire poker.
Stop all the noise, people!
Go stand in line for the soup.
And then go get some rest
On the hay in the unheated club house.
The slop here isn’t so bad —
This thin broth of millet and water.
It could take you an hour
To find one pellet of millet in there
But friends, don’t despair,
They’ll bring in a blind nag,
And you can forget about any bread.
They’ll feed us a crumb once a week.
The nights fly by so quickly.
It’s morning and time for work.
All day long we waste away,
Freezing in the bitter frost.
It’s hard to go to work—
The German comes out to meet us.
He gives us our tasks — better be strong —
He’ll see to its completion.
Like an arrow we fly home,
One thought on everyone’s mind:
To reach camp, toss the shovels
And quickly run off to the village.
It’s hard to run to the
village, but returning is harder.
God forbid Stepan should
catch you at the door,
And give you red stripes.
God forbid Stepan should
catch you at the door,
And give you red stripes.
But we aren’t afraid of the lashing,
And the ramrod doesn’t hurt at all.
We’re ready to endure it all,
Only to make it to another day.
It’s hard to make it to another day,
Unheard-of torments to endure.
But in such damp dirt
Young girls would rather not lay.
But hope is what ever sustains us,
Hope keeps us ever alive.
They are slashing the wings of the eagle —
Then we will ascend the path of joy.
They are slashing the
wings of the eagle —
Then we will ascend the path of joy.
Liubov's testimony and songs
offer important insight into some
lesser known aspects of the history
of the Holocaust.
While teeming concentration camps,
gas chambers, and
industrial crematoria still
dominate popular imagery
of the Holocaust, Liubov's
testimony is more representative
of the experience of Soviet Jews,
who, by and large, were not deported
to the killing centers in
German-occupied Poland.
Instead, in the small towns and
cities of Ukraine, Belarus,
the Baltic states and western
Russia, many able bodied
Jewish men, young children
and elderly fell victim to mass
shootings during the early months of
the German occupation.
Surviving adults were condemned to
forced labor in the ghettos or small
labor camps, living in
constant fear of
ongoing mass shootings.
Liubov's testimony highlights the
experience of Jews in the small,
virtually unknown ghettos
and camps, where grueling labor
and appalling living conditions led
to high rates of injury, malnutrition
and disease.
Budyshche was the third camp
in a series of labor camps where
German overseers and
local politsai transported
Liubov' and her fellow prisoners
as slave laborers
for the Transit Highway IV project
between May 1942
and August 1943.
While these Jewish laborers were, in
theory, incredibly valuable
for the German war effort,
the Nazi regime allowed so-called
accidental deaths to claim
many lives.
And the local gendarmerie added
to the death toll with punitive
shootings and camp liquidations.
Of the four songs that Liubov' K.
shares in her testimony,
"Tuchi nad Budishchem Vstali" offers
the most comprehensive summation
of day to day life in the small,
improvised labor camps along
the Transit Highway IV.
It recounts the frigid winter
conditions in the unheated
clubhouse where prisoners were housed.
It describes backbreaking labor
they performed on the transit highway
and their efforts to supplement the
meager food rations with
food from the local villagers.
It also references the threat of the
cruel guard Stepan,
who meted out punishment for running
off to the village.
Despite the song's somber
lyrics, Liubov'
takes visible joy in performing
it for the interviewers during her
testimony.
As they composed the song in the
camps, Liubov' and her fellow
prisoners borrowed the lilting
melody of a popular Soviet song,
Tuchi nad Gorodom Vstali,
from the 1938 movie
Man with a Gun.
The fact that the original performer
of the song, Mark Bernes
was a Ukrainian Jew was
no doubt a point of great pride
for these prisoners and the melody
a welcome reminder of their lives
before the war.
For these reasons, perhaps,
the song ends with a confident
assertion that the tide of the war
will turn, victory
will come, and joy
will be possible once again.